The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK so we're
going to test it.
Here's testOne.
It just says for name and range
10, I'm going to build
some nodes, put in a few edges,
and then I'm going to
print the graph.
And all I really want to show
you here, is that if we run it
for digraph or we run
it for graph, we'll
get something different.
Yes, I'm happy to
save the source.
Oh, and now the syntax.
It was valid last time I looked,
what have we done
wrong here?
I edit something badly?
Sort of looks valid
to me, doesn't it?
We'll retype it.
Yes, we'll save.
Nope.
Well, it's one of those
days, isn't it?
All right this is a good
debugging exercise for us.
Let's think about how
we go and find this.
I'm sure you've all had
this sort of problem.
Well the first thing to do is I
think I'll just comment out
all of this.
Let's see if I still
get an error.
I do.
All right, well that suggests
that, that wasn't the problem,
so I can put it back.
Now it shows a problem all
the way down there.
So let's see what's
going on here.
Or maybe, I'll just skip this,
but doubtless I'll get in
trouble if I do.
So let's see.
I must have just made a sloppy
editing error somewhere this
morning in commenting things
out for the lecture.
Well, I think what we're going
to do, for the moment, is move
on and hope it goes away.
Now that seems silly.
Sorry about this everybody.
People should look with me, and
someone may see it more
quickly than I can.
In fact, I'm hoping someone
sees it more
quickly than I can.
We've now got a microphone,
and the embarrassment of a
code with syntax error,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: You've
got a sign.
For some reason it wasn't
on the schedule, so--
PROFESSOR: Well just
because we've been
teaching at 10 o'clock.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I know.
Yeah.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: February.
There's no reason to suspect
that we would teach at 10
o'clock today.
MALE SPEAKER: I actually
looked.
I double checked.
PROFESSOR: Well this is
embarrassing, folks.
And I wish one of you would
bail me out by telling me
where my syntax error is.
Well random looks OK, right?
Node looks OK.
And it gets more complicated.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey professor,
can you turn on the
transmitter?
PROFESSOR: No.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, I'll turn
on the transmitter.
But I'm really focused on a
different problem right now.
Guys help!
Where are my TAs?
Why does it keep doing
that to me?
Maybe there's something just
funny going on here.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Restart IDLE.
PROFESSOR: Restarting IDLE?
You think maybe that's
the issue?
We could try that.
Ha!
So it looks like IDLE was
just in some ugly state.
Let's hope.
Yes, all right, so I
didn't have a bug.
It was just IDLE had a bug.
All right, phew.
But we did squander
ten minutes.
Oh well.
So we have the graph, and you
can see when we look at a
graph, we have a node from 1
to 2, an edge from 1 to 2,
from 1 to 1, et cetera.
And that's the digraph.
When we look at the graph, we'll
see that in fact we have
a lot more nodes, because
everything goes in both
directions.
But that's what we expected--
nothing very interesting.
All I want you to do is notice
the difference here between
graphs and digraphs.
Now getting to the whole point,
once we have this
mechanism set up to think about
graphs, we can now think
about interesting problems
and formulate
them as graph problems.
And I want to list a few of the
interesting problems, and
then we'll look at how to
solve some of them.
So probably the most common
graph problem that people
solve, is called the shortest
path problem.
We talked about this
briefly last time.
The notion here is for some pair
of nodes, n1 and n2, we
want to find the shortest
sequence of edges that
connects those two nodes.
All right?
So that's very straightforward.
Then there is the shortest
weighted path, where instead
of trying to find the shortest
sequence of edges, we want to
find the smallest
total weight.
So it may be that we traverse
a few extra edges, but since
they have a shorter
weights, we end up
getting a shorter path.
So we might indirect to
do the shortest path.
This is probably the more
common problem.
So for example, that's the
problem that Google Maps
solves, when you ask it to give
you driving directions.
And you'll notice when you use
something like Google Maps or
MapQuest, you can tell it to
minimize the time, in which
case maybe it will route you
on a freeway, where you can
drive at 80 miles an hour, even
though you drive a few
extra miles.
Or you can tell it to minimize
the distance in which case it
may take you on these crummy
little surface roads where you
have to drive slowly, but you'll
cover fewer miles and
use less gas.
So you get to tell it which set
of weights you care about,
and then it finds
you the shortest
path, given those weights.
We'll come back to this since
we're going to look at some
code to implement it.
Another slightly more
complicated problem to
understand is finding cliques.
So to find a clique, we're
looking to find a set of
nodes, such that there exists
a path connecting
each node in the set.
So you can think of this
as similar to,
say a social clique--
who your friends are.
It's a group of nodes or group
of people that somehow can get
to each other.
It's not saying you can't
get outside the clique.
But it is guaranteeing that from
any member of the clique,
you can reach any other
member of the clique.
And so well, we'll look at some
examples of where finding
a clique is useful.
And the final kind of problem
I want to mention is the
minimum cut problem--
often abbreviated mincut.
So the problem here, is given a
graph, and given two sets of
nodes, you want to find the
minimum number of edges such
that if those edges are removed,
the two sets are
disconnected.
i.e.
you can't get from a member
of one set to a member
of the other set.
This is often a question
that gets asked.
For example, imagine that you
were the government of Syria
and you want to ensure
that nobody can
post a video on YouTube.
You would take the set of nodes
in Syria, and you would
take the set of nodes probably
outside Syria, and ask what's
the minimum number of
communication links you'd have
to cut to ensure that you can't
get from a node in Syria
to a node outside Syria.
People who do things like plan
power lines worry about that.
They want to say what's the
minimum number of links such
that if they're cut, you can't
get any electricity from this
power plant to say, this city.
And they'll typically design
their network with redundancy
in it, so that the mincut
is not too small.
And so people frequently are
worried about mincut problems,
and trying to see
what that is.
All right, now let's look at
a couple of examples, in
slightly more detail.
So what we see here is a
pictorial representation of a
weighted graph generated by
the Centers for Disease
Control, CDC, in Atlanta in 2003
when they were studying
an outbreak of tuberculosis
in the United States--
a virulent and bad infectious
disease.
Each node, and you can see
these little dots are the
nodes, represents a person.
And each node is labeled by a
color, indicating whether the
person has active tuberculosis,
has tested
positive for exposure, but
doesn't have the disease, or
tested negative for exposure,
or not been tested.
So you'll remember when we
looked last time at class
node, and asked why did I bother
creating a class for
something so simple, it was
because I said well maybe we
would add extra properties
to a node.
So now in some sense these
colors would be easy to add.
So I could add to class node--
well I could attribute
color, and call it
red or blue or green--
or more likely an attribute
saying TB state, which would
indicate active not
active, et cetera.
The edges, which you can see
here, represent connections
among pairs of people.
What I didn't bother, you can't
see on these pictures,
is the edges are actually
weighted.
And the weights there
are about how
closely people are connected.
And there are really only two
weights I think they used:
close, someone who say lives in
your house or works in the
same office, or casual, a
neighbor you might have
encountered, but you wouldn't
expect to necessarily
see them every day.
So I've taken a fairly
complicated set of information
and represented it as a graph.
Now what are some of the
interesting graph theoretic
questions we might proceed
to ask about this?
So an important question they
typically ask when diseases
break out unexpectedly is, is
there an index patient?
The index patient is the
patient who brought the
disease into the community--
so somebody who visited some
country, picked up
tuberculosis, flew back to their
neighborhood in the US
and started spreading it.
How would we formulate that
as a graph question?
Again, quite simply.
We would say does there exist a
node such that node has TB,
or maybe not even that,
no, let's simplify it.
You might say, "or tested
positive" because maybe you
can communicate it without
having it--
has TB and is connected
to every node with TB.
Now this doesn't guarantee
that the
patient is an index patient.
But if there is no such patient,
no such node, then
you know that there's not a
single source of this disease
in the community.
How would we change the graph to
model it in a more detailed
way, and remember this is all
about modeling, so that we
could ask a question
or more precisely?
Well we'd have to change to a
more complex coloring scheme,
if you will, in which we'd
include the date of when
somebody acquired the disease,
or tested positive.
And then we could ask those
kinds of questions in a little
bit more detail.
But again once we've built the
model, we can then go and ask
a lot of interesting
questions.
By the way the answer to
this question, for
this graph, is almost.
There is an index patient that's
connected to every node
in the graph, except for the
nodes in this black circle.
They are not connected
to any index patient.
So the CDC actually did that
analysis, and they reached
that conclusion that there
didn't seem to be.
And then later, it came to
light, in fact, that this
particular graph is
missing an edge.
Somebody had moved from
neighborhood A to neighborhood
B, and they had not kept
track of that.
And if they had, they would have
discovered there was a
link that's missing--
an edge that's
missing from this graph--
which in fact would've connected
everybody to the
index patient.
It was an interesting
question.
They only found that, because
they were puzzled about this
tiny little black circle
out here, and started
investigating all the people
in the black circle, and
discovered that one of
them had moved from
one place to another.
What's another question you
might ask once you've built
this model?
Well suppose this is the current
state of the world,
and I want to reduce the spread
of the disease, by
vaccinating uninfected people
so that they don't contract
tuberculosis.
But I have a minimum, it's
expensive to do this, I only
have so much vaccine.
Who should get it?
What's the graph theory problem
that I would solve to
address the question of what's
the best way to allocate my
limited supply a vaccine?
Exactly.
I, by the way, have much
better candy now.
So I think that's where the
minimum cut came from.
Well, all right.
It's better for eating.
It's just worse for throwing.
That's easier to throw.
All right.
It's the minimum cut problem.
I take the people who are
already infected, view them as
one set of nodes.
I take the people who are not
infected, and view them as
another set of nodes, find the
edges that I need to cut to
separate them, and then
vaccinated somebody on one
side of the edge, so that they
don't contract the disease.
So again a nice, easily
formalized, problem.
All right, so that's
an example.
Let's look at another example.
Let's think about the shortest
path problem here.
And we'll do that by thinking
about social networks.
So I suspect that at least a few
of you have used Facebook,
and you have friends--
some of you more, than others.
I see people laughing.
This is someone who probably has
two friends, and is said.
I don't know, or 1,000
friends and is happy.
Who knows--
I don't want to know please.
And I'm not going to
tell you how many
friends I have either.
But you might ask the question,
suppose you wanted
to reach Donald Trump --
erstwhile Republican, vice
presidential candidate, or
presidential candidate.
Say is there a connection from
you to Donald Trump?
Do you have a friend, who has
a friend, who has a friend,
who is a friend with
Donald Trump?
Or for Barack Obama, or
anyone else you'd ask.
Well what's the shortest path?
How many friends do you
have to go through?
This is what's called the six
degrees of separation problem.
In the 1990s, the playwright
John Guare published a play
called Six Degrees of
Separation, under the slightly
dubious premise, that everybody
in the world was
connected to everybody
else in the world
with at most six hops.
If you took all the people you
knew, all the people they
knew, et cetera, you could reach
any person in the world
in six phone calls--
say any person who
has a phone.
I don't know whether that's
true, but this is the whole
notion of a social network.
So if we wanted to look at that
in Facebook, we could
either assume that the friend
relation is symmetric--
if I'm your friend, you're
my friend, which it is.
Or you could imagine a different
model, in which it's
asymmetric.
If it's symmetric you
have a graph.
If it's asymmetric you have
a directed graph.
And then you just ask
the question.
What's the shortest
path from you to
whomever you care about?
And you get that.
You could imagine that Facebook
already knows the
answer to that question, but
just won't tell you.
But they'll sell it to somebody
who has enough money.
All right, So how does Facebook
solve this problem?
They have a very simple piece of
code, which we'll now look
at which solves the
shortest path.
So let's go back.
So here's a recursive
implementation of shortest path.
Comment this out while I'm
in the neighborhood.
It takes the graph, a start node
and end node to print,
and this extra argument
call visited.
We'll see why that's
gets used.
And we'll think about
the algorithm.
This particular algorithm is
what's called a depth first
search algorithm.
It's a recursive depth
first search.
We've seen these before,
often abbreviated DFS.
So if you think about having
a graph of a bunch of nodes
connected to one another, just
for fun we'll say it does
something like this.
What depth first search does
is it starts at the source
node for the shortest path,
let's called it this one, it
first visits one child, then
visits all the children of
those children.
This one has no children.
Visits this child, picks one of
its children, visits all of
its children-- let's say it
had another one here--
and goes on until it's done.
And then it back tracks, comes
back and takes the next child.
Then we have to be a little bit
careful about the circle.
So to summarize it, first thing
we have to say is the
recursion ends, when
start equals end.
That is to say I've called it
and I've asked is there a path
from A to A, and the answer
is yes, there is.
I'm already there.
Now you could argue, and in some
formulations the answer
is not necessarily, you'd say
there's only a path if there's
an edge from A to A. But I've
chosen to make the simpler
assertion that if you want to
get to A, and you're already
there, you're done.
Kind of seems reasonable.
So then the recursive part,
starts by choosing one child
of the node you're
currently at.
And it keeps doing that until
either it reaches a node with
no children, or it reaches the
node you're trying to get to,
or, and here's an important
part, it reaches a node it's
already seen.
And that's what visited
is about.
Because I want to make sure
that when I explore this
graph, I don't go from here to
here to here to here to here
to here ad nauseum, because
I'm stuck in
what's called a cycle.
You have to avoid the cycles.
Once it's got to a node that has
no children, if that's not
the node it's trying to get to,
it back tracks and takes
the next child of the
node it was at.
And in that way, it
systematically explores all
possible paths, and along the
way, it chooses the best one.
So we can look at
the code here.
I've just commented out
something we'll look at later
just as we try and instrument
it to see
how fast it's working.
I've got a debugging statement
just to say whether I'm going
to print what I've been
asked to do, in
case it's not working.
And then the real work starts.
I get the original path is just
the node we're starting
at, if start is end, I stop.
If I get to here, or say
shortest equals none, I
haven't found any paths yet.
So there is no shortest path.
And then for node in the
children of start, if I
haven't already visited
the node--
this is to avoid cycles--
I create a visited list that
contains whatever used to
contain plus the node.
Notice that I'm creating a new
list here, rather than
mutating the old list.
And that's because when I
unravel my recursion, and back
track to where I was, I don't
want to have think I visited
something I haven't
visited, right?
If I had only one list, and I
mutated each time, then as I
go down the recursion and back
up the recursion, I'm always
dealing with the same list.
By getting a new list, I'm
ensuring that I don't have
that problem.
Then I say the new path is
whatever the shortest path is,
from the node I'm currently at
to the desired end node.
And I use the current set of
visited nodes to indicate
where I've already been at this
part of the recursion.
If the new path is none, well
didn't find one, I continue.
Otherwise, I found a path, and
now I just want to check is it
better, or worse, or the same,
as the previous shortest path.
And then I'm done.
Very straightforward.
The only really tricky part was
making sure that I kept
track of visited properly, and
didn't get stuck in cycles.
OK let's run it.
So here's testTwo --
builds the same kind of graph
we've built before.
And then it tries to find
the shortest path.
And I'm going to do it for the
same input, essentially, the
same at edge operations, but
once when it's a graph and
once when it's a digraph.
So you'll notice that it found
two different answers.
When it was a graph, it could
get from 0 to 4 in
essentially one hop.
But when it was a digraph,
it took longer.
It had to go from 0
to two to 3 to 4.
And that's not surprising,
because the
graph has more edges.
And in fact, what we saw is that
in the graph there was an
edge from 4 to 0, but there
was no such edge in the
directed graph.
So again you'll get,
unsurprisingly, different answers--
but very straightforwardly.
Now let's try it on
a bigger problem.
So I've called this big test.
And what this does, is rather
than my sitting there and
typing a bunch of at edge
commands, it just generates
edges at random.
So I tell it whether I want it
to be a graph or digraph, and
then I give it the number
of nodes I want, and
the number of edges.
And it just generates, at
random, a graph in this case
with 25 nodes and 200 edges.
So let's see what
happens here.
So it's printed out the
graph, and now we're
waiting a little bit.
It will eventually
finish, there.
I can get from 0 to 4.
It turns out there's a short
path for this random graph
from 0 to 14 to 4.
It's not so surprising that
there's a short path.
Why is it not surprising that
there's a pretty short path?
It had a lot of edges, right?
I had 200 edges in my graph.
So things are pretty
densely connected.
Why did it take so long?
Well remember what it's doing is
exploring all the possible
paths from 0 to 4,
in this case.
This is very much like what we
saw when we looked at the
knapsack problem, right?
Where, there when we looked at
the recursive implementation,
we saw that well all right,
generating all possibilities,
there were an exponential number
of possibilities there
in the number of items.
Here, depending upon the number
of nodes and the number
of edges, it's also large,
and in fact, exponential.
We could explore a lot of
different paths, but let's see
what's going on when
we explore those.
So what I'm going to
do now, is go back
to our small example.
We'll run testTwo That was the
small one we looked at.
But I'm going to set to print
onto true, and if you remember
what that code did is they told
us what each recursive
call was, what the start node
was and what the end node was.
So it found the same
shortest path.
That's a good thing, 0 to 4.
But how did it do that?
Well it first got called with
the question of starting at 0
find me a path to 4.
It visited the first child
of 0, which was 1.
It said, all right see if you
can find a path from 1 to 4.
It then backtracked and sort
of asked the same question,
can I get from 2 to 4?
From 0 to 4?
And then it said well I can get
from 0 to 2, let me try 2
to 4, 3 to 4, 4 to
4, that's good.
Get to 5 to 4, and then it tried
to find 4 to 4 again.
Here it tried to find
2 to 4 again.
So what you can see, is as I
do that backtracking, I'm
solving the same problem
multiple times.
Why am I doing that?
Because there may be multiple
ways to get to the same node.
So if, for example, I looked at
this graph, what we would
see is I would try and let's
say I want to get to here,
just for the sake of argument,
I'd first say can I get to
here from here.
I'd try this, then I'd
solve here to here.
And I'd do that.
I'd also go from here to here
to here, and then for the
second time, I'd try and solve
the problem here to here.
Now here since it's only
one connection,
it's a short thing.
But you can see if I have
multiple ways to get to the
same intermediate node, each
time I get there I'm going to
solve a problem I have
already solved--
how to get from that
intermediate node to the final
destination.
So I'm doing work I've
already done before.
This is obviously troublesome.
Nobody likes to solve
a problem they've
already solved before.
So what do you think
the solution is?
How would you solve this
sort of thing yourself?
What would you do?
Well what you'd--
yeah, thank you.
This guy is hungry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Some way of storing
information that you've
already looked at.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
What you try and do, is remember
what you did before,
and just look it up.
This is a very common
technique.
It's called memoization.
We use this to solve a lot of
problems where you remember
what the answer was, and rather
than recalculating it,
you just look it up.
And that can, of course,
be much faster.
So it's a fancy way
to say we're going
to use a table look-up.
This concept of memoization
is at the heart of a very
important programming technique
called dynamic
programming.
In the algorithms class that's
taught in this room
immediately following this
class, they have spent at
least four lectures on the topic
of dynamic programming.
But since you guys are much
smarter than those guys taking
that class, we're going to do
it in about 20 minutes, in
today and a little bit
in the next lecture.
All right, so let's look
at an example.
We'll look at a solution.
So I've taken the recursive
implementation we had before,
and rewritten it just a little
bit, to call dp, dynamic
programming shortest path.
And the most important thing
to notice is I've given yet
another argument to the
function, and that's the memo,
which is initially an
empty dictionary.
The rest of the algorithm
proceeds as before, except
what happens here is when I want
to get from a path, the
first question I ask is I say
new path is equal to the memo
of node to end.
So when I get to one of these
interior nodes, and I want to
say what's the shortest path
from here to here, the first
question I ask is do I already
know the answer?
Is it already in my memo?
If so, I just look it
up, and I'm done.
I found it, and I proceed
as before.
If it's not in the memo, well
this look up will fail, and
I'll enter the except clause,
and I'll make a call again.
So this is a very conventional
way of using try, except as a
control structure.
Failing to find in the memo is
not an error, it just means I
haven't yet stored it away.
And as I go, I'll build up the
memo, and then I'm done.
So it's very simple.
So I should ask the question.
Does anyone need me to explain
this again, or does it makes
sense what we're doing
here with a memo?
OK, I'm assuming
it makes sense.
Let's test it.
And we'll first do a
very simple test.
We're just going to use
the same little
graph we used before.
And I'm going to run shortest
path, and dp_shortest path,
and at least confirm that
for one search I
get the same answer.
It's just fire testing it to
make sure that it's not a
complete disaster.
And we do.
We get 0234, 0234.
So at least for one thing,
it's the same thing.
Let's see about performance,
because that's really what we
got interested in.
So we'll go back to
our big test.
And let's go back and for both
of these, I'm going to
uncomment, tracking this global
variable, just keeping
track of the number of calls,
and we'll see whether we get a
substantially different amount
of recursion, in
one versus the other.
So it's built some random
graph again.
This is the non-dynamic
programming one, which as we
recall, takes a bit longer.
I probably should have said--
all right, so it's pretty big
difference.
They found the same
path, 0, 2,3, 4.
But you'll notice the
straightforward depth first
search took over 800,000
recursive calls, whereas the
dynamic programming one took
only an order of 2000--
a huge difference.
If I ran it again, I might see a
slightly smaller difference.
I might even see a considerably
larger
difference.
I've run this on some examples
where the recursive search
depth first took a million, and
got through the dynamic
programming in 50, 60.
But what you can see is there's
a huge improvement in
going from one to the other.
Dynamic programming was invented
in the 1950s by
someone named Richard Bellman.
Many a student has wasted
a lot of time trying to
understand why it's called
dynamic programming.
And you or I could invent
lots of theories.
Relatively recently, I found out
why it was called dynamic
programming, and this is
a quote from Bellman.
"It was an attempt to hide
what I was doing from
government sponsors.
The fact that I was really
doing mathematics was
something not even a congressman
could object to."
So he was doing this thing that
was pretty evil, which
was mathematics, which is what
he thought this was-- the math
of dynamic programming.
And he just didn't
want to admit it.
So he made up a name out of
nothing, and it fooled the
government, and he
got to do it.
Now why do I teach you
dynamic programming?
And we're going to talk a little
bit more about it, the
next lecture.
It's because it is one of the
most important algorithms that
we know today.
It's used over and over again
to provide practical,
efficient solutions to
optimization problems that on
their surface appear
intractable.
They appear exponential.
It says there is no good
way to solve it.
In fact, if it has certain kinds
of properties, it will
always be amenable to
solutions by dynamic
programming, which will most
of the time-- and I'll come
back to the most of the time--
end up taking an exponential
problem, and solving it really
quickly, as we did here.
I could have made this graph
enormous, and dynamic
programming would have given us
a very fast solution to it.
So when can we use dynamic
programming?
Not all the time.
We can use it on problems that
exhibit two properties.
The problem must have optimal
substructure.
What this means is that you can
find a globally optimal
solution by combining locally
optimal solutions.
So we can again see that with
our graph problem, that we can
combine the solutions from nodes
at a distance from the
root node to get the solution
of getting there
from the root node.
If I know I can get from A to B,
and I can find the optimal
solution from B to C, then I
can use that to find the
optimal solution from A to
C. So it has optimal
substructure.
The other thing it has to have
is overlapping sub-problems.
And that's the thing I
emphasized earlier--
that finding the optimal
solution involves finding
optimal solution to the same
sub-problem multiple times.
Otherwise, we could build this
memo, but we'd never
successfully look up
anything in it.
And so the algorithm would give
us the right answer, but
we'd get no speedup,.
So it's this property that we
need to know that we'll get
the correct answer--
that when we combine the local
solutions, we'll get the right
global solution.
It's this property that gives
us an indication of how much
of a speedup we can
expect to achieve.
How many problems will we not
have to solve, because we can
look up the solution?
We'll come back to this.
And we'll see how it applies to
another problem that you've
already looked at say the
knapsack problem, to give us a
fast solution to that, so that
if you want a answer, go back
to a previous problem set, and
take the full database of
classes, you'll be able to solve
it quickly using dynamic
programming.
OK, see you next time.